you might recognize rachel powell as the  woman who participated in the  january 6th riots and then when the  judge ordered her to wear a mask pending  her release from prison  uh she defied that by wearing a mask  that was nothing but  mesh in clear defiance of the judge's  wishes good morning everybody welcome to  mr bookman's page  but not surprising when she posted these  photos to social media  the judge issued an osc in order to show  cause why he shouldn't bring the hammer  down on her for  her obvious defiance of his order well  not surprisingly  rachel powell apologized to the judge  and said that well she was misguided by  lana del rey who had some sort of clear  mask  sorry about that judge you really just  can't make any of this up which is why  i'll probably see her  and you in court